two-time super bowl champ with the
quarter with the giants uh quarterback
eli manning joining us on behalf of
yahoo sports
mobile home for sports fans offering
live streams of local and primetime nfl
games
the new watch together feature we'll
talk to eli about that
coming up what did you do yesterday eli
uh yesterday i uh i had a busy day i uh
i watched the giants play
i did a uh i had a home gate which is a
type of uh tailgating for the first time
you know with uh
my old teammate sean o'hare but uh then
you know went to the playground with the
kiddos so full day
we were gonna go over under tvs in your
man cave
okay so paulie you want to set the the
uh line
eli loves his college football as well
you need a lot of tvs i'm going over
three and a half is the over under i won
over three and a half yeah i'm gonna go
under
i think eli probably two tvs in the man
cave how many tvs do you have eli
well first i need a man cave to oh
wow create this i mean i kind of have
i've kind of create created it
um but you know this is new to me this
is like you know this is i'm gonna i've
never needed a man cave before i was
always playing
on on sundays and gone on the weekend i
wasn't watching football
all day so now in this kind of next life
uh maybe i gotta start
i gotta start figuring that out a little
bit well if you wanna slip away from the
kids
and the wife you gotta have a man cave
how many kids do you have now
uh i lost count after three i think i
have four kids
four kids you need a man cave i need a
man
okay so it's in the works we're starting
to brainstorm some things now
when you're watching the giants play can
you watch as
eli from new jersey or are you watching
as the former quarterback there
you know uh i think it's a combination i
think
um you know it's you know since i know i
know the players you know these are
these are my ex-teammates these are my
buddies i
i you know have had dinner with them and
i've had them to the house they've you
know
i've watched them and some of them kind
of uh grow up i feel like a little bit
and so uh you know i'm rooting for them
i'm rooting for
the individuals i'm rooting for the team
because i you know you know know the the
the merits and the tish's and you want
it for the fans and so
um you know so i am i am pulling for him
and i do
you know kind of if there's a bad play i
cringe if there's a touchdown i i
celebrate
um but the kind of the i guess the best
part
about just being a fan and not not
having so much invested is that
after the game it does you know i don't
i don't it doesn't affect the rest of my
day i can go to sleep fine i woke up
this morning feeling great and
you know it doesn't it doesn't linger uh
like it used to
did you ever talk to peyton about
broadcasting games together
uh we have not discussed that that's
never uh
never come into a conversation do you
think that would be a good idea
i was wondering because your guys
relationship it'd be fun
you guys you know definitely needle each
other and you
you know the game and the timing would
be great i think to do something like
that but
would you be interested in doing that
the only thing um you know about
broadcasting that that
scares me a little bit it's just the uh
the travel i'm used to you know when i
was playing
football you know you had you know half
the games or home games so you're kind
of around saturday you you know stay in
a hotel saturday night you're home
sunday
as a broadcast you you know a lot of
times you got to be at that friday
practice
in the morning so you're leaving
thursday or friday morning you're going
all weekend with four kids and their
activities you know
i'd just be afraid of missing so much
uh of their life and and so you know
um you know i think that's that's kind
of the one thing that that scares me and
and
you know maybe down the road but i think
i didn't want to commit to something
that would be so time consuming
uh so you know so quickly right at right
after retiring
but do kids make retiring easier
you know it's uh i think it was
it was kind of thrown right at me you
know it's like right when i retire and
then a month later
we go into a pandemic and set you know
four kids at home
homeschooling these zooms and it's it's
like
whoa whoa whoa you know if this if we
don't go back to school
i'm gonna go play for somebody this year
that only a giant
thing there's a little asterisk by it
saying not in a pandemic i will go be a
backup
i'll go anywhere and maybe to get
get away for a little bit but thankfully
they are kind of back in school and i
don't have to
you know try to you know remember how to
throw a football again but it was
uh it was it was uh some tough moments
but it is fun
but it's also good when they're when
they're uh busy and they
uh are around their friends and they're
in school and doing their activities
when's the last time you picked up
football
uh i picked up a football since since
the last game
you know which was what december 29th or
whatever it was for us last year i've
picked up a football one time
i've thrown i've thrown passes one time
uh
a buddy a good a good friend of mine
called me up and said hey i'm i'm
around your area can can you come throw
passes to me i said
no i really i really i've not thrown in
seven months he said
please i need you to come throw so i i
went through them
uh about 40 40 routes how long would it
take for you to get ready to play again
i i could you know i could not i
couldn't play i mean just
i'm uh you know just just getting
physically ready getting your arm ready
you know learning on offense
you know there's this you know there's
no way no and i have no desire
uh what do you miss most
you know you you miss you missed the
locker room you missed the guys
you missed you know the training even
training camp and just being there
the fun that happens in a locker room
the you know the the celebrations after
a win
uh the plane rides after a win you miss
all like the good moments you miss
uh you know the moments when you're
smiling you don't miss the losses you
don't miss
and you know you know uh the the monday
morning meetings after a loss
um and just you know just the the toll
it takes on you
and our family uh after you experience
those so that's that's the toughest part
we're talking to eli manning the former
quarterback two-time super bowl champ
and uh you won two super bland vps
didn't you
i believe yourself yeah you did and you
got you got
the one car that i know that i gave you
you gave me yeah do you still have that
corvette
well dan i think oh no you auctioned it
off right
i auctioned it i received the
little card that you sent to me that had
you know kind of had
after i won the mvp that you read off
presenting me with the keys to this new
corvette
yeah uh that you were so gracious to
send to me so i auctioned that off for
charity for
um for the all-in challenge uh going to
you know organizations to feed people
who are
going through tough times so uh so the
car is gone i've shipped it off
a person from denver bought it uh it's
not payton
and uh and and i gotta go i'm gonna go
visit them in a few
in a few months and uh and you know let
them you know let them see
let them you know teach them how to
drive that baby
wait so you're gonna go visit the guy
who won the auction
that was part of the auction so he gets
the car and i get i'm gonna go you know
visit and uh
for a little bit and drive around and oh
that's cool and
figure it out and so uh yeah so i'll go
do that
and uh in a few months uh tell me what
uh you're doing with yahoo sports with
the new watch together
feature yeah i mean i think now
especially where everything's
a little bit different you can't go to
games you can't have these gatherings
uh and so you know verizon yahoo kind of
got together and created this
watch together where you can invite up
to three friends or three family members
or
three anybody to uh you know watch watch
a game on yahoo sports app
and so you can get any uh live local
or prime time game and you know kind of
get that sense that you are still
watching it with your family if you if
you had season tickets and you you went
with your
or their family or friends and you went
to every game you can still come
together
and have those moments where you're not
just sitting on the couch by yourself
watching tv you're
you're you know kind of getting that
interaction and on a live video chat
and uh i think it's it's a great idea
and uh you know i think uh
that's that's kind of what we're getting
into these days in this world is
is you know more experiences watching
the game from home and
and this is what yahoo sports has done
so you can download the app it's free
and uh and watch the games and watch
your favorite teams
you got to get a man cave there are you
gotta get a magnet are you gonna have
more kids
are you are you done without four no
more no more kids then we're kids we got
the three girls and then we had the
little the little guys
one and a half and uh we're good we're
good to go we're sitting has ole miss
offered your son a scholarship yet
not officially officially i don't think
uh hey it's great to see you i'm glad
you're doing well thanks for joining us
thanks dan really appreciate it good
seeing you pal that's eli manning
just turned 39 back in january